[Music]
in July and then we're very excited
about this we're taking our show down to
comic-con for the second year in a row
[Applause]
and this year they're aware of it ya
know we're gonna be airing shows from
comic-con in San Diego Wednesday July
20th through Sunday July 24th now this
is really cool
the company that makes pop vinyl figures
Funko has once again created four new
limited-edition Conan pop figures now
these are collectible vinyl figures that
we're gonna give out exclusively to our
audiences in San Diego now we gave these
figures out last year and you remember
this yeah as insanity and raisi
yeah I mean they were selling as some of
them were going on eBay for like
thousands of dollars it's crazy well
this year Funko has created four new
characters which are really cool we have
them right here there's stormtrooper
Conan right here that's a
[Applause]
there's a look at this one right here
Ghostbuster Conan which I guess
technically technically means I'm a
woman then look at this there's Superman
Conan you got to have Superman in there
and then finally I think my favorite is
Joker Conan last year yeah otherwise
known as Conan without coffee and make
up first thing in the morning now these
are kind of a big deal last year as I
said people were selling these for a
fortune on eBay now usually with
merchandise like this a celebrity can do
certain things to increase the items
value for example I could sign it
yeah assign each one or I could take a
picture with each one well I wanted to
go the extra mile to increase the value
of these pop figures that's why I took
the time to personally shower with each
and every one of them Wow this took me
six straight days I did thousands and
thousands of them but each figure has
showered with me Conan O'Brien
please zoom in would you please get in
there
Toastmasters yes get in there
[Applause]
[Music]
that was an erotic experience for
everybody and what I say that so angrily
will be giving away a ton of Kona pop
figures during our week at comic-con
look for details on how you can get one
at team koco.com slash comic-con conan
at Comic Con Wednesday July 20th through
Sunday July 24th we have a lot of really
fun stuff planned
so next
you